oh well here's something that's going to
make you feel really good
guess who i just secured as the
headliner for the unity concert
chip macaque no yes nice wait no i don't
want to touch your hand jiffy cap
is the most amazing 17 year old country
singer in the entire world he's like
indiana's sweetheart we are huge
chipmunks that's what uh his fans call
themselves i don't know why chipmunks
cause the animal no that's too simple
yeah okay
his latest song beautiful like my mom
parentheses support the troops has like
two million hits on youtube she don't
care about no fancy trans she's just a
mom from
old south bend get home safe boys
and thank you for protecting our freedom
let's play it again i'll bring the girls
you bring the beer
and the troops will bring the freedom uh
we're sorry to interrupt chip hi we just
wanted to say we are
such big fans it's an honor to meet you
yeah well i'm very blessed and it's
always nice to meet my amazing fans that
keep me going
you're the real superstars thank you can
someone give me one of those lunch
stacks
and stack them for me this time cheese
on top or no one gets paid
you got it chip it's my dad got such an
idiot
we wanted to talk to you about the unity
concert
in pawnee can you do it yeah ah
no i'm sorry i got a previous engagement
it's a bummer
oh here you go chip look at that the
cheese is on top
of turkey you dick i want ham
i'm sorry son they were out of hand all
right well maybe i should just let mom
be manager then
pick him up skip ew this guy's the
worst i mean it sucks that they didn't
have ham but you can't treat your dad
like that i know he's a monster
but we need him your job's not that hard
okay just anticipate my needs
anticipating chip we know that you have
that important other engagement
yo i gots to get that haircut snoop it's
not just pawnee that needs you it's the
entire region
permission to speak son pawnee is kind
of the gateway to that whole region
they do buy a lot of albums they sharing
buying toothpaste
bunch of dirty hicks what if we fly me
in and out same day so i wouldn't have
to spend a night in your crap town
excuse me pawnee is a good town with
good people from all walks of life
plus it is an amazing place to raise
kids and start a family you think i care
about that
look i can do whatever i want all right
if i want to shoot a paintball gun at my
dad
i'm gonna do it good shot son
i'm proud of you you're crazy this is
over okay pawnee does not need you and
you should know that when you shook my
hand earlier there was pee on my palms
that makes us sound like hicks we're not
shut up stupid okay let's go andy
you